Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Okay,
so what did I tell you about
waves?
I said let's take a concrete
example instead of talking in
generalities.
You say wave is the disturbance
of some medium.
The medium I chose to study was
a string, under some tension,
clamped at both ends.
Then, you pull it and you
release it, it's going to be
doing something.
This height,
from the normal position,
at the point x,
is the actual variable,
of ø of x and
t.
So, at every point x
along the string,
there's a displacement of the
string in the transverse
direction;
that's ø of x
and t.
I showed you that this
ø obeys the following
equation: d^(2)ø over
dx^(2),
equals 1 over v^(2),
d^(2)ø over
dt^(2),
where v^(2) is tension
divided by mass per unit length.
I'm going to change my notation
into force, because T is
also used for time period;
so it's going to be,
it's going to get me in trouble
very soon.
So, let's just change the
formula to what's used in the
books, v^(2) is F
over ì;
F is the tension on the
string.
So, what--how did we get this?
Let me remind you how I got
this, okay?
Let's undo the v^(2) as
T over ì.
What we are saying is
Td^(2)ø over
dx^(2),
is equal to ì;
d^(2)ø over
dt^(2).
This is very easy to
understand, the meaning of the
equation, I claim,
is just F = ma.
You realize that this is the
a of the string,
moving up and down,
this is the acceleration,
and this is the mass per unit
length.
So, imagine a tiny segment of
width dx.
If you multiply both sides by
dx, that is the mass of a
little segment.
ì times dx is
the mass;
this is mass times acceleration.
The left-hand side is the force
on it.
Why is this the force?
I tried to explain to you,
that if you took a piece of
that string, then the tension is
pulling like that there
[pointing to the board]
and like this here,
and the two don't cancel
because if you resolve this
force into vertical and
horizontal parts,
that into the vertical and
horizontal part [pointing to the
board], you can see this is
going to be bigger than that.
So, the slope itself is
changing and this is the rate of
change of the slope.
Another way to think about it
is if you remember your
calculus, the second derivative
of a function is the curvature
of the function;
so that if you draw a graph
like this, that's a function of
negative curvature,
that's a function which is
positive curvature.
It says, if the string has
negative curvature,
the force is down;
if the string has positive
curvature that probably means
you are below your normal
position;
then it's getting a force
upwards.
So, it's the curvature of the
string that leads to a net
force.
One of you asked me a very good
question after class which
is--the question was,
"You took care of the vertical
forces as T sin (è +
Äè) here,
and T sin è here,
and you did all the
cancellations.
How about the horizontal part?
That's also not quite balanced,
the angles are not equal."
But the point was sin è
was approximated by è
for small angles,
but cos è,
you guys remember,
begins as 1 minus è^(2)
over 2 and so on;
but we are not keeping track of
things more than the first power
of è in the calculation.
So, cos è is just 1,
in this approximation,
and tan è and sin
è are both equal to è.
That's a small angle
approximation.
That's why the horizontal
forces, the fact that they don't
quite match is an error to the
next order in è,
but the vertical forces are
proportional to the first power
of è,
and that's what we kept.
That's the origin of the wave
equation.
Then, you know you did the
cancellation of dx and so
on and you went back to that
form.
Then, I said how about
solutions to this equation?
Well, if you have a little more
time I can tell you how to get
the solution to this equation.
I don't have that much time.
So, what we will do--going to
do, is to be content with
writing down a solution,
then convincing you it's a
solution, analyzing its
properties.
So, the solution I wrote down
looked like A cos (kx -
ùt).
And I said, "Well,
is that a solution of this
form?"
Well, take it,
put it into the equation and
take all the derivatives.
First of all you guys should be
able to see that the A
will cancel on both sides.
Do you see that?
So, if you put this here,
two derivatives will pull out a
k^(2),
two derivatives here will pull
out an ù^(2).
Therefore, if you want the two
sides to match,
you will want the ù^(2)
side divided by v^(2) to
equal the k^(2).
That means ù = k
times v.
That's the only condition.
If that is satisfied,
if this ù is k
times v,
you have a solution.
No, and A stands for
anything;
you can have any amplitude you
want.
Of course that's a little bit
of a fake.
Why is that not really
literally true?
Yes?
Student: [inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: No,
I tell you it's real and
positive, and two miles long.
Yes?
Student: [inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Not only that.
The whole calculation assumed
it was a small displacement
problem, right?
That's why sin è and
tan è are all equal to
è and cos è is
roughly 1.
So, once you make an
approximation and you get an
answer, you should not blindly
apply the answer to
circumstances that are not
valid.
So, even though the answer says
you can have any A that you
like, in practice you shouldn't
use it for A,
which is so large that the
small angle approximation fails.
Alright, so A is anything.
So, let's put in the result
I've learned,
namely, that ù = kv,
and write it as k times
x - vt.
And here's where we were at the
end of the class.
What this tells you is that
this guy is some function of
x - vt.
It happens to be A cos,
but it turns out any function
of x - vt actually
satisfies the wave equation.
That's a very interesting
exercise for you calculus buffs.
Take f unknown function,
whatever you like,
but it's not an arbitrary
function in which x and
t appear any way they
like,
they appear only in this
combination.
So, make up any function you'd
like, hyperbolic cos of
x - vt,
that's a solution to the wave
equation.
Why?
Because if you start taking
derivatives, if you call this
variable w,
you'll find that partial
derivative of x and
partial derivative of,
with respect to T are
all connected with derivatives
of w;
and then if you do the chain
rule, you'll find it satisfies
the wave equation.
Then, I tried to convince you
that because of that,
v is actually the
velocity of the wave.
Let me tell you why.
Take any function you like,
at a given time,
t = 0,
it has a certain shape.
Our cosine has a certain shape,
but take any shape you like,
a t = 0.
Let us say it has peaked here.
If you wait a little bit,
if you'd like it to be peaked
at x = 6,
for example,
if you wait a little bit,
this term minus vt,
is subtracting it from it,
you got to add to this the same
amount so that the peak now will
be there.
The amount by which it has
moved is in fact exactly equal
to vt.
In other words,
if the vt becomes non
zero, x should become non
zero by the same amount,
if you want to ride the crest
of that wave.
That means the signal is moving
to the right.
So, it turns out you can have
x - vt or x + vt,
they're both solutions to the
wave equation.
With a minus sign the signal is
moving to the right;
with a plus sign it's moving to
the left.
That's a summary of what I did
last time.
So, last time we derived the
wave equation;
we took this particular
solution.
Alright.
The next thing I want to do is
ask the following question,
"What is k and what is
ù?"
So, let's take this function's
ø, of x and
t, which is A cos kx -
ùt.
See, a function of two
variables is hard for us to
visualize.
We are all good at explaining,
visualizing a function of one
variable, but this is a function
of two variables.
Understand why it's two.
Every point on the string has a
variable ø at that
point, and that variable can
vary with time.
That's why ø of
x and t is needed
to describe the vibration of an
extended body like a string.
But a point particle,
you just need one or two or
three coordinates.
Alright.
Now, I look at this function
and I say, "Let me at least
understand this function at
t = 0."
A t = 0, drop that term;
in other words,
this is a snapshot of the
function.
What does it look like?
If I take a picture at t
= 0, then I vary space.
Well, that's cos kx,
and you can all plot cos
kx, versus x.
It's going to start out at
A, then it's going to
oscillate because that's what
the cosine does.
Now, this distance from one
peak to the next peak,
we call the wavelength.
It's also the distance from one
trough to another trough or from
one point to an identical point.
That distance where you repeat
yourself is called lambda (ë).
What is the relation of
k to ë?
Now, you got to ask yourself,
when x was 0,
this angle was 0.
I've got to increase x
till it come back to what's
essentially is 0.
For A cos,
you are back to essentially 0
if this angle is 2ð.
It can also be 4ð or
6ð, but the first time
you are back to 0 is when it's
2ð.
Therefore the length ë,
up there, has a property that
k times ë is
2ð,
because if I move to the right
by an amount ë,
the angle in the cosine are
changed by 2ð.
So, this number called k
is related to the number we all
understand more intuitively by
this formula.
It's the inverse of the
wavelength, up to this factor
2ð.
Now you can say,
well, you picked time t
= 0;
maybe if you picked time
t = 1 second you would
have gotten a different picture.
Think about it.
If I put t = 1 second,
as long as it's a fixed number,
that's some fixed angle
ö;
it's just going to shift the
whole pattern by some amount;
it won't change the fact that
the peak to peak distance is
still ë.
Because what's happening as a
function of time,
we have seen very generally is
that this whole pattern is going
to slide to the right.
So, I want to combine this
picture with a dynamic picture
by saying, if you now vary time,
imagine this sliding by.
If you are sitting somewhere
here, or some point,
that'll be the height for you,
and as time goes by that'll be
the height and that'll be the
height and that'll be the height
and that'll be the height;
all these things will go past
where you are.
So, let us now ask,
"What does it look like to a
person sitting at a certain
location, as a function of
time?"
In other words,
the waves are being
manufactured in the ocean.
Let's say they're being sent
towards the shore.
You stand in one place;
the wave's going to go past you.
So, you will bob up and down,
and that's what I want to
understand.
So, I pick some location.
I pick x = 0 for
convenience, then ø at
x = 0,
as a function of time looks
like A cos
ùt.
I didn't miss the minus sign;
for a cosine,
it doesn't matter if you change
the angle to minus the angle.
So, plot the same graph now
this time as a function of time,
and ask what happens.
Well, you start with a maximum
and you bob up and down.
This is a picture at one point
where the water or the string
goes up and down.
So we like to call this,
from one maximum to the next
maximum, the time period [T].
That's the time over which the
wave repeats itself.
Well it follows then,
that ù times the time
period is 2ð,
because when I put little
t equal to time period,
I've gone from this maximum to
that maximum.
Therefore, ù is
2ð over T;
in other words k and
ù, which we put into the
wave, are related to the time
period and the wavelength
through this reciprocal formula.
So, if you like you can write
the wave as A cos
(2ðx/ë -
2ðt/T).
It's strictly equivalent,
you write it any way you like.
This makes it clear that when
x changes by ë,
nothing happens to the cosine
because when x changes by
ë you are adding a
2ð to the cosine.
Here, it's clear that if you
add to little t an amount
of time big T,
nothing happens,
because 2ðs don't
matter.
So, this makes very clear the
periodicity in space and time;
but this is more compact
because if we don't want to
carry 2ð's and
ës in this complicated
form,
we give a new name to
2ð over ë and
2ð over T.
Okay.
What about the velocity of the
wave?
Remember, it satisfied this
condition, so ù over
k.
But now, let's write this in
terms of those new guys,
2ð over T
divided by 2ð over
ë, is ë over
T.
So, the velocity of this--This
wave is called a sine wave or A
cosine wave or a plane wave.
You got to understand waves in
water and waves in string always
have a velocity.
If you pluck the string and let
it go, a little blip will travel
from left to right.
But not every wave has a
wavelength or a time period.
This is a special function that
has periodicity in x and
t.
In other words,
if you go to a lake and drop a
rock, it'll send out some waves
and after awhile they'll spread
out.
It's not going to happen over
and over and over again.
But if you want a wave to be
present for all time,
for all space,
you should keep on agitating
the water.
That's what we imagine here is
the source of this wave is to
keep manufacturing these waves
from left to right.
So, you must remember that in
general every wave on a string
or in a medium has a velocity
but not every wave has a
wavelength or a time period.
Any pulse that travels from
left to right with speed
v is a possible
displacement of the medium.
This is a particularly simple
situation we study.
For that simple situation,
the velocity is connected to
wavelength and time period in
this fashion,
or you may also like to write
it as ë times the
frequency.
So, that's a very easy thing to
remember, because if you're
trying to get a velocity,
it's going to be some distance
over some time,
the only distance you can think
of for a periodic wave is a
wavelength;
the only time you can think of
is the time.
It turns out that ë
over T is in fact simply
the velocity.
Here's another way to
understand this.
Suppose I have a string that
goes on to infinity,
and I'm catching it at this end
and I start wiggling this
string.
When I start wiggling this,
these pulses will travel--let
us say they'll come up to this
point.
Let's wait one more second.
In one more second I would have
manufactured a few more of these
pulses and the wave will look
like that.
How many pulses would I make
per second?
f;
how long is each one, ë?
So, that's how much the wave
has advanced in one second;
that's why it's the velocity.
You're making ë-sized
objects, f at a time,
f per second,
and pushing them out;
so the front of the wave
advances a distance ëf
in one second,
that is the velocity,
that's one way to understand
why ëf is equal to
v.
Okay, so now,
I consider another aspect of
these waves, and that's the
energy in the wave.
First of all,
you've got to understand a
vibrating string has some energy
compared to a string which is
not vibrating.
Okay, you have an intuitive
feeling the vibrations are a
cause of energy.
I want to calculate now the
energy in a string vibrating
according to this formula here
[pointing to the board].
Now, if it's an infinitely long
string, the energy in it is
infinite, so you don't define
the energy of an infinitely long
string,
you define the energy of a
piece of a string;
in fact, you talk about energy
per unit length.
So, if you take a string,
it's been vibrating for a long
time, and the waves have been
manufactured on the left,
they've gone out far to the
right, we don't care how far.
Take a portion of the string,
of length dx,
and ask, "How much energy does
it have?"
We have already seen that if
you sit at one point,
the string just moves up and
down.
It executes simple harmonic
motion.
When the string has gone out
all the way fully,
it's like a spring which has
been extended maximally.
That's when the string stops,
turns around and comes back;
when the string has come to the
horizontal position,
that's the normal equilibrium
position for a mass and a
spring,
that's when it's moving the
fastest, and overshoots and goes
to the other side and goes back
and forth.
So, every part of a string is
just undergoing simple harmonic
motion--that's pretty obvious
from this.
So, we just need to write down
the energy.
So, how do you write the energy?
The energy is going to be
either kinetic or potential,
or the sum of the two.
Now, you can find the energy
whenever you like because it's a
constant.
Let's find it when the velocity
is a maximum,
like for harmonic oscillators,
it's like finding the velocity
on a mass that's just swinging
past the normal position,
x = 0.
There the entire energy is
kinetic energy,
it's ½, ìdx is the
mass of the segment I'm looking
at.
What's the maximum velocity?
You guys remember from harmonic
oscillators, what's the maximum
velocity that a harmonic
oscillator has,
whose motion is given by this?
Yep?
Student: [inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Yes,
ùA.
This is--You're getting a Yale
education.
So, that's the difference
between 40,000 dollars and
10,000 dollars is that this is
not w,
but ù [laughter].
Okay?
By the way, I could not get any
of my kids to say ù;
they keep saying w.
I'm trying to have more success
with this class than with my own
offspring.
But if you go to the outside
world, if you talk to any
physicist, if you say w,
they'll think you're talking
about the width of something.
So, you have to say ù,
ok so the Greek alphabet is
essential to communication.
So, this is Aù is the
maximum velocity and I've got to
square that.
Now, this is the energy of a
segment of a length dx.
So, what we normally define is
a quantity called little
u, and that is the energy
per unit length.
That means just divide by
dx, and you get ½
ì, A^(2),
ù^(2).
It is just the kinetic energy
of a segment of unit length.
It's the total energy,
but I chose to compute it when
it's all kinetic.
Yes?
Student: [inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: µ is the
mass per unit length.
You understand?
You take the string,
you find its mass and you
divide by length.
There's so much mass per
centimeter or per meter,
that's ì.
That's why if you go back to
the derivation of the wave
equation we were thinking in
terms of ì.
Okay.
Now, we can ask another
question, "What is the power
sent into this wave by the
person exciting the medium?"
See, the string is tied to a
point at infinity.
But let's say it started
oscillating a while ago,
and this is the part of the
string that has started moving,
and I'm still shaking it here.
Let me wait one second.
If I wait one second,
this part of the string is now
activated, and what's the energy
contained in the extra segment?
It's the energy per unit
length, ½ ìa^(2)ù^(2),
times the velocity.
That is the power I have to
give in to produce this wave
continuously.
Do you guys follow that?
If I wait one second,
a segment of length v,
has now started moving,
in the front end,
because the wave is being
produced by me and sent out into
the medium.
The distance it travels in one
second is v,
and all of that extra segment
is now vibrating,
with this energy per unit
length.
So, this is the extra energy
per second I have to give,
and that's the power.
That power is provided by the
person shaking the string.
A special property of life in
one dimension is that this wave
goes undiminished in amplitude.
You can go 10 miles,
100 miles from me,
the amplitude is still the
A that I produced here.
That's because all the energy
goes along this line.
It's sort of atypical.
What typically happens is when
you live in, when you take into
account vibrations such as
sound,
in two or three dimensions,
if you have a tower on top of
which you put a speaker,
just making noise,
the energy radiates out in
concentric circles.
And the power at the source is
now spread over bigger and
bigger spheres.
So, in three dimensions we have
the notion of intensity,
which is the power per unit
area.
What I'm saying is,
if you've got a speaker there
that's sending out sound waves,
I take a one meter by one meter
window and hold in front of me
and I ask how much power crossed
this in one second?,
That's intensity.
You don't have the notion in
one dimension because you cannot
hold a window in one dimension.
Three dimensions,
you take a little square,
one by one meter,
and you define intensity to be
power per unit area.
Of course, it doesn't have to
be one meter big.
You can take a tiny square,
provided you divide by the area
of the tiny square,
that is this.
So, what do you think will
happen if there's a speaker
mounted on top of a platform
that's radiating power at the
rate P?
The intensity you get where you
are, I hope you understand,
will be simply [P over]
4ðr^(2),
where r is the radius of
this sphere and you are a
distance out from the center;
and the power is going out
uniformly in all directions,
and your share for the whole
sphere was P;
the share for the unit area on
the sphere is P divided
by 4ðr^(2).
And that's measured in watts
per meter squared.
Yes?
Student: [inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: This one?
What else do you think it
should have?
T for time period, why?
Student: [inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: It's energy per
length.
But if I wait one second,
the wave has gone a distance
v times one second.
And so, the extra energy I've
given every second has to pay
for v more meters.
Student: [inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar Yes,
this is the energy per second,
that's the power,
that's correct.
So, if you check your units you
will find it's got energy per
second.
Okay, so this is called the
intensity.
And for sound we have another
way to measure intensity.
We define something called beta
(â), which is 10 times
the logarithm of the intensity
divided by a standard intensity.
The standard intensity has a
value, 10 to the minus 12 watts
per meter square.
And this is called the number
of decibels.
So, you measure the loudness of
a sound in decibels.
You must have heard that
everywhere.
You look at your amplifier will
have so many dBs in it.
So, what's the dB talking about?
The dB says your speaker is
making some--sending out some
energy;
stay wherever you want,
at a certain distance from the
speaker, see how much power is
passing past the unit area,
that's the numerator,
divided by the standard number.
People all agreed on dividing
by the standard;
then, take the logarithm of
that to the base 10 and multiply
by 10.
That's called the number of
decibels.
So, for example,
if the power coming to me was
say 10 to the minus 11 watts per
meter square,
then I over
I_0 will be 10
to minus 11, divided by 10 to
the minus 12,
which will be 10 to the 1;
and the log of 10 to the 1 is
just 1, and â will be 10
dB.
So, a 10 decibel sound is a
factor of 10 bigger than the
standard sound.
But here's the interesting
thing.
Suppose the intensity is 10 to
the minus 8 watts per meter
square.
That is a thousand times more
intense than this one.
But let's look at â.
â becomes 10 log of 10
to the 4 now;
because 10 to the minus 8
divided by 10 to the minus 12 is
40.
So, when intensity goes from
some number to something a
thousand times bigger,
the decibel goes from 10 to 40.
The decibel grows much more
slowly than the actual
intensity;
in fact, the decibel is keeping
track of how many zeros there
are in the power,
it grows logarithmically.
So, every time I add an extra 0
to the power,
you go from 10 to 100,100 to a
1000, the decibel goes up just
by, from 10 to 20 to 30 to 40.
That's why 80 decibels can be
incredibly loud,
80,90, 100;
100's a very painful number of
decibels.
And I believe people use
decibels because the human ear
is able to take a whole range of
intensity and hear it.
The ability of the ear to
listen to intensity -- you might
think there's a very narrow band
you can hear -- you can hear a
very wide band,
where the intensity ranges over
several powers of 10.
In that case,
instead of dealing with numbers
that go all the way from 10 to
the minus 5 to 10 to the plus
something,
if you deal with the logarithm
of the number then it's more
manageable.
So, you can imagine trivial
problems involving finding
â, or given â
finding the intensity and so on.
Okay, so now I'm finished with
basic properties of waves.
Decibels is a property just for
sound, you don't apply that to
light.
And the whole standard
intensity
I_0--intensity
is well defined for everything;
even electromagnetic waves have
intensity;
it's the power coming per unit
area.
But when applied to sound,
if you take the log and
multiply it by 10,
that's the decibel level of
that sound.
Okay, now for another totally
different property of wave
propagation, which I'm going to
again apply to sound,
is the familiar Doppler effect.
So, the Doppler effect is the
well known phenomenon that if
you have a source of definite
frequency,
like a siren in a fire truck,
when the fire truck is coming
towards you, you hear a higher
frequency,
and when it's gone past you,
you hear a lower frequency,
and we just want to know why,
and by how much.
So, to proceed with this,
I want to remind you this
relation, ë times f is v.
So we're going to bear that in
mind.
So let's take a source that is
sitting still,
and you are standing here,
listening to the sound.
The waves go by you and you see
a certain wavelength.
That's the distance from one
crest to the next.
Now suppose the source is
moving to the right,
at a certain speed,
u;
u is the speed of the source.
So what does the pattern look
like?
It's not too hard to visualize
that having emitted one crest,
it's moved to the right before
it emits a second crest.
So the pattern will get
crunched in a forward direction
like this.
So the waves will get squashed
because the spacing will have
been ë, but now it's less than
ë because it's moved to the
right to emit the second crest;
so spacing from crest to crest.
The new ë, which I call ë
prime, will be ë minus the
distance the source travels in
that time.
In the time it takes to emit
one more pulse.
That is the time period.
So let me write it as ë minus
u over f, because T is 1 over f.
So, what is the new frequency
that I will hear?
The new frequency I will hear
will be the velocity divided by
the new wavelength.
By the way, you've got to
understand that even though the
source is moving to the right,
the velocity of sound is not
altered by that process.
A moving truck does not emit
sound at an increased speed in
the forward direction or
decrease.
The speed of sound is
controlled by the medium in
which it travels.
If the medium is air it can
travel only at that speed.
So you don't have a new
velocity when the thing begins
to move.
The velocity is the same in
air, as long as the air is not
moving.
So let's write it as v over ë
minus u over f;
multiply top and bottom by f.
So we write it as f times
something, which is v divided by
ë f, minus u,
and we fiddle with that and
write it as v divided by v minus
u,
because ë f is v;
and divide top and bottom by v.
This is something you'll find
in every possible textbook.
So I don't want to take too
long to go over the details.
The main trick is in writing
this equation.
Once you've got this,
the rest of it is just algebra.
The point is to realize that
the waves get crunched,
because when you emit a crest
and you rush towards that crest,
and emit a second crest,
you've reduced the spacing by
your velocity,
multiplied by the time between
such emissions,
which is the time of vibration
of the siren.
So this is the formula.
The frequency is the normal
frequency divided by 1 minus
something.
So one minus something is less
than 1.
So the frequency will go up.
If you want to see what happens
here, behind the thing,
you have the option of doing
the same calculation behind,
and I think it's very obvious
what you will find,
you will get 1 plus something.
So we'll write both solutions
as minus or plus.
In one case,
the frequency will be
increased;
other case the frequency will
be decreased.
So one way to think about it is
if the source is coming towards
you, use the minus sign;
if the source is going away
from you, you use the plus sign.
But you should know intuitively
at least what sign to pick.
You've got to know if the
source is coming towards you the
frequency will go up,
and if it's going away from,
you it'll go down.
So, you pick the sign using
that common sense.
Somebody had a question in the
back.
Yes?
Student: With
relativistic speeds does that
change for light?
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Ah.
Relativistic speeds,
a lot of things happen,
that's correct.
When you handle light you got
to be very careful.
The velocity of light will be
the velocity of light,
but the frequency will change
for many reasons.
First of all,
the ambulance clock and your
clock no longer agree,
so there is something called a
transverse Doppler shift,
where even if it's not coming
towards you or going away from
you, or it is going in a circle,
you're sitting in the middle.
It's going tangentially,
so it's not coming towards you
or away from you,
you will still feel a Doppler
shift.
That's because it's a moving
clock and therefore it'll slow
down.
So, relativistic problems are
more complicated.
Yes?
Student: How does this
deal with sonic booms?
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Okay,
sonic boom comes in,
in the following thing:
f prime is f
divided by 1 minus u over
v.
Let me embellish the formula by
writing use of s,
where s means source.
Okay, when the source is
moving, this is the formula.
In relativity,
it was chock full of formulas
like this, but we never worried
about what happens when the
denominator vanishes because you
just cannot approach the speed
of light.
You can approach it but you
cannot reach it.
But the speed of sound is not
an upper limit at all,
and you can have an ambulance,
or a plane, that eventually
travels faster than this.
So that's when,
imagine the waves getting
crunched till all the crests are
piled right on top of each
other, and that's when there is
the sonic boom.
And if you go faster than that,
the way the wavelets emerge
from you, so that you leave
behind a trail,
there's nothing in front of
you.
So, if a jet plane is coming
towards you, faster than the
speed of sound,
you won't have time to get out
of the way because it'll hit you
before the sound waves hit you.
Okay, so sound is not the
absolute limit.
So, there are possibilities of,
I mean, every time you go on
the Concord, well,
not any more but when you did,
you would be crossing this
thing pretty soon after takeoff,
because you'd go several times
faster than the speed of sound.
Okay, the last Doppler thing I
want to do is the opposite one
where the siren is emitting nice
spherical waves,
but you are rushing to meet the
siren.
You are going with the speed
u, sub-observer
[u_0].
Then, what happens?
So, let's see what to do.
What's the frequency at which
you will see crests?
If you sat there and did
nothing, you'll see them at the
normal frequency.
But now you are,
these waves are spaced at
distance ë apart,
but your velocity,
relative to sound is now
u_0 + v,
your relative velocity.
Sound is moving to the right,
you are moving to the left.
So, with respect to these
crests you are zipping at a
speed u_0 + v.
And the crests are spaced at a
distance ë apart;
there's nothing wrong with the
spacing between them;
they are just like shown here.
You are just rushing to meet
them now, from your side.
So, how many will you intercept
in a second as this;
this is the relative speed and
that's ë.
So let's write this,
u_0 + v;
ë = v divided by
f.
So, I'll bring the f
upstairs.
And that you can write as
f times 1 +
u_0 over
v.
So, when you move towards the
source, the correction factor
appears in the numerator;
when the source moves towards
you, correction factor appears
in the denominator.
You got to use common sense to
see if it's plus and minus and
so on.
It's pretty obvious if you're
rushing to meet the waves it's
plus;
if you're running away from the
waves it's minus.
Then, you can go on and on and
ask what happens if you are
moving and the ambulance is also
moving;
then, you can combine the
formulas.
But I don't want to do that,
that's not the whole course,
dedicated to theory of sound,
but this is just to tell you
how to reason in the two special
cases, source moving and
observer moving.
Okay, so now,
the rest of the class is going
to be focused on one essential
property of waves.
So, the whole time I'm going to
do just this one important
property of waves that has to do
with interference of waves.
Look at the wave equation I
wrote down.
It's a linear equation.
You see that?
Don't be fooled by this
d^(2)ø.
That doesn't make it quadratic;
it's the first power of
ø on both sides.
Then, do the following exercise
in your mind.
ø_1 is a
solution, ø_2
is a solution.
Add the two equations.
You can check that
ø_1 +
ø_2 is also a
solution.
So, these waves also have the
property that--what that really
means is the following:
If you make some sound and
you're sending some waves,
they make a certain pattern
that travels through space.
Then, I turn you off and I turn
on another speaker here;
let's say the speaker makes a
sound.
If you and the speaker are
making sound at the same time,
then the air displacement where
I am will be simply the sum of
the two.
So, if one cause produces one
effect, a second cause produces
a second effect,
then both are turned on;
the wave they produced will
simply be the sum.
You can simply add them because
that respects the--satisfies the
wave equation.
So, all I'm going to do from
now until the end is take a
variety of situations where I'm
going to be adding to waves.
So, the simplest problem is the
following.
Pick a certain spot.
You just sit there and listen
to two waves.
So, you're not going to look at
the wave as a function of space.
It's a function of time;
somebody is making the waves
and sending them to you.
The first wave looks like
ø_1 = A cos
ù_1t.
That's the second source of
sound, which is A cos
ù_2t.
I've chosen the two to have the
same amplitude,
but not necessarily the same
frequency.
You want to add these two,
and you want to see what you
hear.
So, what you will hear will be
ø_1 +
ø_2,
which will be A cos
ù_1t + cos
ù_2t.
Now you can do the
trigonometric identities and
figure out what has happened,
but you have to think a little
bit about what's going to
happen.
Think about these two waves.
If they have the same
frequency, it's trivial,
right?
If the ù_1
=ù_2,
ø = 2 A cos ùt;
where ù is the common
frequency.
That just means they reinforce
each other.
At every instant you get double
what you got before.
But if the frequencies are not
equal, then initially they are
in step.
This cosine is 1,
and that cosine is 1 and the
amplitude is 2A.
As time goes by
ù_1t and
ù_2t start
differing, so the cosines are
not in step anymore.
And what can happen after
awhile is the two cosines are
offset by half a cycle or the
angle between them is ð.
Then in fact, they will cancel.
Then, if you wait long enough,
again, they will be in step.
One way to think about it is
imagine two runners going around
in a track.
If they have slightly different
speeds they start out together,
they go around and one starts
lagging,
behind the other,
and they will be on different
parts of the circle,
and a time will come when
they're on opposite parts of the
circle.
When they're on opposite parts
of the circle,
the angle or difference between
them is ð,
and that's when we say they
cancel.
If you wait long enough they'll
again line up,
but with one difference,
one guy would have done one
more revolution than the other;
then again they will be in step
and out of step.
That's what you expect the
formula to give you.
So, you got to go back and use
the trigonometric formula.
And the answer is,
2A cos
(ù_1 -
ù_2,) over 2
times t,
times cos (ù_1 +
ù_2), over 2
times t.
This says cos A - cos B
is 2 cos A - B over 2,
cos A - B over 2.
Alright, so we are interested
in the case where
ù_1 is very
nearly equal to
ù_2 so two
frequencies are very close.
A typical situation--You have a
piano tuner, the piano tuner
hits the fork,
it vibrates at some frequency,
maybe 440 Hertz,
and then your piano is slightly
off, maybe it's 439.
What sound do you hear when you
put them together?
Well, let's look at this.
If ù_1 -
ù_2 is a very
small number,
this cosine here is changing
very, very slowly;
this cosine is oscillating at
roughly the--it's oscillating at
the average of the two
frequencies.
So, if one was 401,
and one was 399,
this is oscillating at 400,
but here ù_1 -
ù_2 is 2,
divided by 2 is 1.
So, it's oscillating much
slower.
So, what will you get if you
plot this?
Think of the whole thing as an
amplitude that's slowly varying
with time.
So, we have done it the other
day when I wrote e to the
minus ã,
t over 2 times some
cos ùt;
this is an envelope that
controls the amplitude.
That day it was falling
monotonically,
but here it'll oscillate very
slowly.
So, let me plot this cosine
here.
This is just the amplitude,
but with that amplitude,
this guy is oscillating like
crazy.
So, what I do mean to convey is
that you'll have oscillations
like this.
So, it'll be loud,
silent, loud,
silent.
So, you will hear another beat,
this is called a beat,
in which you will hear a hum in
which together they add and
cancel, add and cancel.
And we want to calculate the
beat frequency.
Now, the first guess is to say
the frequency of the beat is
(ù_1 -
ù_2) over2,
because that's what seems to
appear here.
But actually,
the correct answer is the beat
frequency is simply
ù_1 -
ù_2.
And I will tell you why.
At t = 0,
when the cosine had a value 1,
you got an amplitude 2A.
Wait till ù_1 -
ù_2 over 2 is not
equal to 2ð,
but equal to ð,
I mean times t.
If this whole combination is
equal to ð,
this number becomes a negative
number of ø's 2A,
but that just means it's here.
But if you multiply that huge
negative number by the cosine,
it is still oscillating very
wildly here, as much as it is
here.
In other words,
5 cos ùt and -5 cos
ùt have the same amplitude.
The minus doesn't change the
fact that it's having large
excursions from plus 5 to minus
5.
So in other words,
I'm telling you to compare some
answer like this,
5 cos 400t,
-5 cos 400t.
Plot this and plot this;
you'll find if 400t is
very rapid oscillations,
this has an amplitude as big as
this one.
And the ear is just picking up
the amplitude;
the ear is not picking up
anything else.
The ear is just picking up the
loudness of the sound,
so it will seem to be loud now
and loud there.
But once you've gone from here
to here, you only had to change
the argument of this whole thing
by ð and not by
2ð.
That's why the beat frequency
then happens to be simply the
difference in frequencies.
Or I ask you to do another
thing, if you're not happy with
this.
Go home and do the following
thing.
One is vibrating as
ù_1t,
the other is vibrating as
ù_2t.
Find out when the difference
between the phase angles is
equal to ð;
that's when this guy and that
guy will cancel each other;
that's when you come here.
Then, you ask yourself when
they'll come back to where they
are, 2ð.
Ask for when the difference in
phase is 2ð and you will
find that that occurs at the
frequency, which is what I told
you.
So whether you can,
if you found this factor of 2
confusing, you've got to
understand the argument I gave
you.
That in order for this thing to
sound just as loud as it did at
t = 0,
it's not necessary that this
number come to 2A,
it's good enough if it comes to
minus 2A;
because minus 2A times
the rapid cosine,
which is oscillating on top of
the minus 2, will also look like
plus 2;
you cannot tell the difference.
So, beat frequencies are used
to tune instruments.
So, what the piano tuner does
is to strike the fork,
and strike that thing on the
piano and listen to the two,
if they're not quite matched,
you'll hear a slow hum that
goes up and down in intensity.
You keep on fiddling with it
till it goes away.
That's when you match the two
frequencies.
So, beat frequencies have a lot
of interesting applications in
physics.
In fact, when you go to a radio
station, you know,
this station is what,
960 megahertz or something.
No way your ears can hear that.
That's not a frequency of the
sound;
that's a frequency of the
signal, called a carrier wave.
Then, you modulate with that,
with something,
and you produce a beat.
It's the beats that we are able
to hear.
Anyway, this is something
fairly simple,
a trigonometric problem.
Now, I will do a slightly more
complicated problem,
where I'm going to add two
waves.
And we'll do a lot more of this
in the next term but right now
you're supposed to have first
pass at this topic;
this is called a double slit
experiment.
You have a source of waves here.
The source is so far away that
you can treat these to be just
parallel lines,
and you hit a double slip,
namely, an impenetrable barrier
with two holes in it.
If you want think of it as
water waves, and you've erected
a wall on your estate,
where there are two holes.
So, you know what'll happen,
right?
These two holes will themselves
start generating their own
waves.
And you want to stand on a line
here, go up and down and ask
what's the water doing where I
am.
So, first take a point exactly
midway between these two points.
What are you getting?
You are getting a signal from
here, and you're getting a
signal from here.
One signal travels that way;
the other travels that way
[pointing at diagram on board].
Do you understand that because
you're symmetrically located,
the two signals will be in step
when they come to you?
Because they were on step when
this front hit this double hole,
and started making its own
waves.
So, these waves are emitted in
step, they march along and come
to you without,
with the same time delay.
So, when a crest from this
reaches you, a crest from that
will reach you,
trough reaches,
trough reaches.
So, you'll just double the
answer.
So here you will get,
ø will become
2ø, or A will
become 2A.
If you have an amplitude
A from this and A
from this, you will get
2A here.
So, the water will be very
choppy there.
If you're living on a little
boat, the boat will rock up and
down with amplitude 2A.
If you shut off this hole,
the amplitude will go back to
just that from one hole,
it'll be A;
2 gives you 2A.
That's what makes a lot of
common sense.
But pick another point here,
I will tell you how to pick
that point, so that these two
lengths are not equal.
So, let's call that length
L_1 and length
L_2.
Suppose L_1 -
L_2 is half a
wavelength.
As you know between every two
crests there is a trough where
the function is minus the
amplitude, at the crest is equal
to plus the amplitude.
So, if you're half a wavelength
apart, when a crest from here
appears, a trough from here will
appear.
When a trough from here
appears, a crest from here will
appear.
In fact in every instant,
whatever comes here,
minus of that will come here.
Let's understand why.
The way the wave travels is
2ðx over ë,
where x is,
say, measured from here.
For the other guy,
it is 2ð times x
prime over ë,
or x prime at that
length.
If that length is longer than
this, by ë over 2,
if this is x plus
ë over 2,
look what you're getting extra:
2ð times ë over
2 divided by ë,
is really cosine of ð,
plus what the other person got.
But cosine of ð added to
ð added to anything
changes the cosine to minus
itself.
So, the way to think about it
is when you're half a wavelength
behind coming from here,
whatever this one does,
this does minus of that.
Because shifting by half a
wavelength is adding a ð
to the cosine;
adding a ð to the
cosine changes it to minus its
value at every instant.
Not only does crest come with
trough and trough comes with
crest, every possible
displacement comes with minus of
that from here,
and you get nothing here.
So, this is called an
interference minimum.
Or we say, here the
interference is constructive,
and here we say the
interference is destructive.
How will you find the point of
destructive interference?
It's a matter of simple
geometry.
You measure that length,
and you measure that length;
take the difference and set it
equal to ë over 2.
That's the first destructive
interference.
That's a very interesting point
to sit in.
Look what it's telling you.
It says if you sit here with
your boat, the boat won't move
at all, even though there are
two holes letting waves in at
that point.
That's the principle behind
noise cancellation.
You can actually cancel one
sound with another sound if you
bring the second sound off by
half a cycle.
So that if you had only one
hole in the wall that you'd
built between your little estate
and the beach,
and the waves from here were
rocking the boat,
miraculously putting a second
hole at the right place can
actually calm the waters where
you are.
And the minute somebody blocks
one of these holes,
the water will get choppy again
where you are.
It's the property of waves that
two waves can lead to nothing,
but one wave cannot because two
waves have a chance of working
against each other and
canceling.
This is something you've got to
get very straight.
Now, if I go further up here,
until I reach a point where the
difference in those two lengths
is the full wavelength,
then I'm back to being in step.
Of course, a full wavelength
means that these are not doing
the same length,
but this is differing from that
by a whole wavelength.
That means when the 13^(th)
wave from here arrives,
the 14^(th) or the 12^(th) from
here will arrive.
But we don't care,
as long as a crest comes with a
crest;
we're happy where we are.
So things get--start with
constructive,
destructive,
destructive;
it oscillates both above and
below the midpoint.
Yes?
Student: How is the
amplitude of the wave,
once it goes through that
amplitude [inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: It could be,
it need not be the same.
It all depends on the aperture
and so on.
But what is clear by symmetry
is that these two have the same
amplitude.
In practice,
we believe the amplitude will
also be the same,
because amplitude has to be
continuous when you go through a
slit.
The water cannot be jumping up
by two inches before the slit,
and suddenly on the other side
jump to different lengths.
Amplitude is always continuous.
So in fact, this amplitude and
that amplitude will be equal.
You can also see from the wave
equation if the ø was
not continuous;
dø/dx will be infinity.
There's no room for any
infinities in the equations.
ø will be continuous;
in fact--Yes?
Student: [inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Here?
Student: Yes.
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: You're not able to
read this equation,
because it's very badly
written.
Let me tell you what I tried to
do.
Cos 2ðx over
ë;
let's pick a certain time,
so that I don't worry about
ùt.
In fact, let me write it as
L_1.
The other one is cos
2ð,
L_2/ë.
I'm adding two waves.
Suppose L_2 =
L_1 plus half a
wavelength.
Then, this one becomes
cos 2ð
L_1/ë + ð.
Right?
L_2 = L_1 +
ë/2.
This is the
L_1.
If you put a ë/2,
times 2ð over
ë, you get a ð.
Then, you've got to understand
that whenever you add a
ð to a cosine,
you get minus the cosine,
without the ð.
There you can see this guy is
producing a signal,
which is exactly the minus of
that guy.
I did this at t = 0,
but you can put an ùt
to both.
But nothing changes the fact
that when you subtract the same
ùt from the 2,
it doesn't change anything.
So, I didn't worry about the
time.
It's the spatial mismatch
that's the problem here.
Okay, now sometimes people
write this formula for
destructive and constructive
interference as follows.
There's an approximate formula
that's very handy.
The correct way to do this of
course is simply measure that
distance and that distance and
take the difference,
okay?
In other words,
if L_1 -
L_2 = më,
where m is an integer,
1,2 et cetera,
or plus minus 1,
plus minus 2,
it is constructive.
If it's a half integer,
which we like to denote as
follows: m + ½
ë, again m = 0
plus minus 1,
et cetera is destructive.
The way of writing--m is
usually the standard symbol
people use for integers;
m and n are
common symbols for integers.
So, if the path difference is
an integer multiple of
ë, it's harmless;
if it is a half-integer
multiple of ë,
it's harmful,
meaning destructive.
The whole approximation has to
do with what is L_1
- L_2.
One is to actually measure
these lengths exactly,
and using Pythagoras' Theorem,
given the difference between
the slits, given the distance to
the screen.
If that distance is d,
one can do the math and
calculate it.
But here's what people do.
They say imagine this screen is
very, very far away.
Very far away so that the rays
leaving this are actually
parallel because they meet at
infinity, and that's where your
screen is.
It's not really at infinity but
it's far enough for this
purpose.
Then, you can tell very easily
that the extra length traveled
by this wave is just this part
here.
Do you see that?
Because this part cancels out.
So, drop a perpendicular here,
those two are equal in length
going out in infinity;
that's the extra section.
How long is the extra section?
With that as d,
distance between the slits,
if that angle is è
here,
then we say d sin
è is = L_1
- L_2.
And that's what you want to be
either më or (m +
½)ë,
for constructive and
destructive.
But there's a way to relate
this è here to this
direction.
They are the same angle.
You may want to go look at your
book where the graphics are
better than mine.
But I'm telling you the same
old trick we used from incline
planes.
If you got two lines,
this line and this line,
the angle between them is
è,
then the perpendicular of the
two lines have the same angle
between them.
Perpendicular to this line is
this one, and perpendicular to
the screen is the horizontal
one.
So, è is also that
angle.
Therefore, the way you will do
any of these problems is,
suppose someone says find out
when I get the first destructive
interference,
given that length to the
screen, and someone says,
"How far should I move?"
What you do is,
you say d is the
distance between the two slits,
sin è equal to say
ë over 2,
for destructive.
Solve for è.
Because the d is known,
sin è is not known,
you want it to be ë
over 2;
ë will be given to you.
Once you get the angle,
you're basically telling the
person to go at that angle,
and that's where the intensity
will be a minimum.
But then, it's trigonometry to
understand that d over
L is just tan è.
So, if you knew è,
you can find D over
L.
So, D over L is
tan è.
So, the problems you can get
are either ë is given to
you and è has to be
found,
or è is given to you,
ë has to be found.
Somebody can say in some
experiment with waves I find the
first minimum at that angle,
what's the wavelength?
The distance between the slits
is so and so.
But the basic idea is really to
find the path lengths;
take the difference,
set it equal to either integer
multiple or half integer
multiple of the wavelength.
Okay, last of the interference
problems has to do with all
these musical instruments,
and it goes like this.
Take a string.
Now, there's a wall here and
you start shaking it,
and ask what happens.
So, let's say I shake it just
once, and it sent a pulse like
this, moving to the right.
Well, this pulse,
by the time it gets to this
place where the string is
anchored and not free to move,
it cannot vibrate here.
So, how is that going to happen?
Well, some forces will be
exerted on the string by the
wall to make sure that the
signal the wall sends out,
along with the signal you send
out, add up to zero at the point
of contact,
because no vibration there is
allowed.
And the result of that is that
when a signal goes out like
this, it comes out reflected in
direction and inverted in its
sign.
For those of you who wanted
more satisfactory proof of this,
let me say the following.
Suppose there is no wall.
I saw you send a signal,
and I manufacture a mirror
image of that to the right,
traveling towards this point.
The two are coming near each
other, and when they meet,
by design, I've arranged it so
that this one and this one,
when they overlap,
are exactly opposite of each
other, so that they cancel each
other at this point.
Then, they go through each
other, and this will come out
here, that'll go to the other
side.
But throughout this encounter
-- here's the punch line --
throughout the encounter this
point was not asked to move,
because the two waves
cancelled.
That means even if I put my
finger there,
it won't make a difference to
this problem because that point
is not planning to move anyway.
It also means that if you put a
barrier here that doesn't allow
the string to move;
it doesn't change the outcome.
That's the reason we convince
ourselves that the incoming
pulse this way comes out that
way.
Okay, now what I want to study
is not a single one-shot pulse,
but a pulse that looks like
this, A cos kx -
ùt.
A continuous signal goes in,
how does it come out?
It comes out as [-A]
cos ùt + kx.
So, I've reversed the amplitude
and I've reversed the direction
of motion.
So, this is a result of an
incoming wave,
and the one that's sent back by
the wall;
together they coexist.
But that goes in and that comes
out, and together they form what
I will find in this region.
I keep sending stuff to the
wall, the wall keeps sending
that back to me,
and both exist.
Well, you've got to do another
trigonometric identity,
to show you that this is really
2A sin kx,
sin ùt.
I don't want to go through the
trigonometric identity.
But what I want you to notice
then, is that the resulting
physics looks like this.
Here is the wall,
at a given point x,
the amplitude is 2A sin
kx, and it oscillates with a
frequency ùt.
And if you draw it sin
kx, it's going to look like
this.
So, whenever kx = ð,
if kx = ð where that
distance is ë/2,
there is no vibration.
There is no vibration.
This is called a node;
in between is an anti-node.
This kind of thing will be set
up all the way back.
Now you see what that means.
So, this point is not going to
vibrate.
If I put another barrier here,
it won't make any difference,
because that point is--these
two waves add up to zero
identically at that point.
If you put your finger there it
won't matter.
So, in addition to making no
difference if you hold the
string there,
it also doesn't matter if you
hold it here.
So, what that means is that if
you turn the problem around and
say, look, I give you the
following problem,
I give you a string which is
clamped at these two ends,
what are the possible
vibrations of the string?
They have to look like the
following.
Your string length has to be
equal to that or that or any of
these multiples.
That means what can happen in
your string is either that,
or it can do that,
or something with more and more
lobes in it.
These are the allowed modes of
vibration of the string,
fixed at two ends.
What I want to extract from
this is what sound will you
hear, what frequency will you
hear.
So, you have--this is the
family of problems that you guys
are expected to do.
So, you have to think as
follows.
That is the length.
How is the length related to
the wavelength,
that's all you got to figure
out.
Is it clear to you guys that
this is half a wavelength?
If you've got that, you're home.
Because you're saying half a
wavelength is equal to L,
or the wavelength is equal to
2L;
the frequency is the velocity
of sound divided by the
wavelength, which is the
velocity divided by 2L.
That's the frequency you will
hear from this guy.
When it vibrates like this,
I think it's clear to you that
it's gone through one full cycle
here, this is ë = L.
You do the whole thing you will
find frequency is now
v/L, which is two times
the lowest frequency,
which we denote by
f_0,
which means the fundamental
frequency.
So, the bottom line is very
simple.
A string clamped at two ends,
and has length L,
can only vibrate in either the
fundamental frequency or an
integer multiple of the
fundamental frequency.
And when it does that,
the two ends of the string will
be nodes, and you can have any
number of anti-nodes in between,
provided you start with a node
and end with a node.
Now, this is also valid in the
following problem.
Take a tube,
clamped [correction:
should have said blocked]
at both ends,
and there are some longitudinal
sound waves going back and
forth.
This is transverse waves on a
string;
this is sound waves going back
and forth.
You realize the sound waves
going back and forth cannot go
back and forth at this wall or
at this wall.
Therefore, the motion of the
air molecules has to have a node
here and it has to have a node
here.
So, the possible modes of
vibration for sound also look
exactly like this.
The frequencies will be the
same for vibrations on a tube,
closed at two ends.
The only subtlety,
which I don't want you to
forget--;Here,
the picture really talks about
the string moving perpendicular
to the length.
This does not indicate here
that the sound,
the air molecules are going up
and down.
This is the amplitude for
longitudinal vibration.
If this number is three inches,
it means the molecules here are
moving back and forth by three
inches.
So, we just out of habit plot
everything on the y axis;
that doesn't mean the motion is
in the y direction.
For a longitudinal wave the
motion is side-to-side;
this is the extent of
side-to-side motion.
So, the only problem where you
may get stumped is the following
one.
I will tell you how to do that
and then we are done.
Take a tube, like this.
It's closed here and it's open
here.
You know, take a Coke bottle or
something and try to blow on it;
you hear a certain sound.
Why is it picking that one
frequency?
That's what I want to
understand.
Now, since I'm making the noise
here, here is where the
amplitude will be the biggest,
and of course there's nothing
doing at this end,
because that's a wall which
cannot go back and forth.
So, what pattern can I draw?
Take a minute and think about
it.
I want a maximum vibration
here, nothing here.
The lowest one I can draw looks
like that.
The next one I can draw is
constrained to have a maximum
here and then a minimum at that
end.
Now, what is the relation of
the length of the tube to the
wavelength?
I think you can see the length
of the tube is now a quarter of
a wavelength,
it's not from here to the top.
Coming down is the other
quarter and then the other half
is missing.
So, what's the frequency?
It's equal to v/ë;
it's going to be 4v/L.
I'm getting the frequency to be
velocity divided by wavelength,
and I bet you will get this.
Oh, did I get it wrong?
Oh yes, I'm sorry,
it's v/4L.
4L is ë.
Now, what's the answer here?
What is the relation of the
length to wavelength?
The length happens to be a half
a cycle plus another quarter,
is 3/4^(th) of ë.
And the frequency,
if you do this,
will be 3v/4L.
And this is all I want you to
notice.
That in this peculiar problem
where one end is open and one
end is closed,
the frequencies are odd
multiples of the fundamental
frequency,
3 times that,
5 times that,
7 times that.
And in exams,
you can be asked a variety of
questions, either this one or
some other exam you take some
time later in life.
You should be able to do
the--Let me do one practice
thing.
Here's a tube open at both ends.
Draw me the lowest frequency
you can draw.
I want an anti-node here,
an anti-node here,
but between them I got to have
a node.
So, it'll look like that.
Then, you can draw more
complicated patterns,
provided the two ends look like
this.
And I think you can see here,
that this is half a wavelength.
So, L = ë over 2.
And again, you will find here
all frequencies are integer
multiples of the fundamental.
So, the story is this,
as long as the two ends are the
same, both open or both closed,
all frequencies are integer
multiples of the fundamental
one.
If you got a funny situation,
one end is open and one end is
closed, you'll get odd multiples
of the fundamental.
But I think you might have to
go do some reading in the book.
I don't have a better way to
explain this,
and this is somewhat easier
part of the course,
and I think you should try to
be on top of this particular
topic.